[Music]
ryan is in cleveland ohio hi ryan how
are you
hey dave i'm doing so well it's uh good
to talk with you good what's up
well i'm just going to get straight to
the point here
um
kind of question about a used car
purchase so my wife and i we have 118
000
in student loans no other debt outside
of that and our take-home is between 150
and 160
and we have two paid for cars
unfortunately one of them
really can't be driven anymore so we're
just trying to figure out why a good
price
um
you have to do an e-check and her or one
of the cars can no longer pass the the
e-check why
uh computer issues is what we were told
one opinion get a second opinion
and the computer costs how much to fix
well uh the mechanic that we were
talking to
mentioned it can be
up to a couple thousand
and then he said that's no guarantee
that it's going to you know start
working well sounds like we need another
mechanic that sounds crazy expensive for
a computer issue so what is the car
worth
um well the car is a salvage title so
depending on if we go to a dealer or
sell it
it could be up to maybe 5 000 but
probably not much more than that
okay you probably don't spend 2 000 on
this car
to fix it but i think i'm going to get
some other opinions and see if i can't
get this computer thing fixed and rigged
for a while longer is are there other
problems with the car
uh no it honestly it runs pretty well um
nice car subaru legacy it's just uh the
computer issues our sensors and the car
uh are really starting to pile up here
yeah
well i'm not spending two grand on it
i'm getting rid of it and buying another
comparable comparably priced car this is
not a reason to go and buy a fifteen
thousand dollar car because you got a
hundred thousand dollars in debt
yep so you know if you wanna flip it
over break even buy something in the
five thousand dollar range pay cash for
it if you can't fix it for a grand if
you can fix it for a grand i'm probably
driving it but not for two grand
okay that makes sense to you i
appreciate it yeah that's great i really
appreciate that right because it sounds
like it's not a bad car 500 or a
thousand dollars is worth throwing at it
but if it's going to be two grand it
starts to it starts to not make sense
anymore and you want to bail out of it
yeah and they they take home 12 or 13
grand so they could cash flow a
comparable car in a month and not slow
down their debt snowball much at all
yeah and so if you want to flip it over
and just you're tired of screwing with
it buy you 5 000 that's fine but the
thing you got to fight is oh i got this
huge amount of student loan debt it's
going to be a little while it's going to
be two years three years before you
knock that out sounds like then uh it's
easy to go well that's permission to go
buy mama a nice car no it's not no it's
not it's permission to buy mama a
different car that rolls yeah with an
engine that turns that simple and it
passes the e stuff there you go